you guys like romcoms yeah I love
romcoms Yeah well tell me everything I I
mean I spent my life in
that thank
you okay thank
you what romcoms do you like and is it
true you're not afraid to shed a tear in
one The Wedding
Singer
yes I got to tell you every time I watch
that movie I'm so glad you're not Julia
gulia thank God I was end up with Glen
gulia we all have Adam s that saved you
from that he's so I just rewatched it
for the first time in 25 years boy did
it make me emotional this the gestures
the big gestures that's what's in I
think chasing you onto the plane and
sing in the sun you got to have a
running you got to yes you need that at
the end of the movie Billy ID do too
make an appearance I love that movie